في الصين قال مسؤول القطاع الصحه في مؤتمر
الصحفي ان عدد حالات الاصابه الشديده
بفيروس كورونا في المستشفيات الصينيه
ازالو مرتفعا وان معظمها من كبار السن
واشار المسؤولون الى ان اجماليه عدد
الوفيات المرتبطه بكرونه بلغ نحو 60 الف
حاله بين الثامن من ديسمبر والثاني عشر من
يناير الجاري واضاف ان الصين ستعزز
امدادات الادويه والمعدات الطبيه
وستعزز وتدريب العاملين الطبيين على مستوى
القاعده لمكافحه في المناطق الريفيه واشار
ايضا الى الصين ستعزز المراقبه الصحيه
للسكان المعرضين لمخاطره عاليه
مدير مكتب الجزيره ناصر عبد الحق ناصر الى
الى ماذا تؤشر كل هذه الاجراءات الصينيه
في ما يتعلق بكرونا في البلاد
نعم محمد هذه الاجراءات تاتي بعد ان اعلنت
الصين عن هذه الارقام الكبيره حيث كانت
الصين منذ بدايه رفع القروض القيود تعلن
عن ارقام قليله ما دعى الكثير من
المراقبين الى الاستغراب مقارنه باعداد
الوفيات التي حصلت في دول اخرى عند اجتياح
فيروس كورونا فقد كانت الصين تعلن عن
حالتين او ثلاث حالات وفايه يوميا ولكن
بعد ذلك اعلنت الصين انها هلا لن تعلن عن
حالات الوفاه بعد ذلك وبعد شهر من رفع هذه
القيود ياتي الان همم المسؤولون في الصين
ليعلنوا عن هذه الاعداد ما يقارب 60,000
منذ بدايه شهر ديسمبر همم الماضي وقالت ان
معظم هؤلاء او حالات الوفاء كانت لكبار
السن حيث كان معدل اعمارهم يتوح يعني يصل
الى 80 همم عام وبالتالي طبعا همم معظم
هذه الوفات كانت من كبار السن ممن يعانون
في الاصل من همم امراض مزمنه كامراض في
الجهاز التنفسي وغيرها وامراض القلب
وبالتالي قالت السلطات بان
5,500 حاله وفاه فقط من هذه همم حاله هي
حاله وفاه مباشره بفيروس كورونا وباقي
الحالات حالات وفاه لكبار السن همم يعني
تتعلق بامراض مسلمه كانوا يعانون منها
وهاتا واتت اصابتهم بفيروس كورونا لكي
تكون شديده عليهم السلطات الصينيه طبعا
تكثف الاجراءات لتقليل عدد حالات هذه همم
الوفاء شكرا